hello everybody and welcome to yet
another tutorial on a new opportunity to
come and work for the EU institutions
we have published a competition to
select specialists in the field of
Transport ad7 grade competition and as
usual we have published on our website
this infographic
showing you the five steps to take to
become a successful candidate
and in this tutorial I will walk you
through these five steps and explain the
details so you missed out on nothing
before applying
let's have a look at the eligible
eligibility requirements first
I said it's an ad7 competition
and the requirements for this
competition are quite specific as you
can see on this slide here
you are eligible when you have either a
master degree in one of the mentioned
Fields there law economics engineering
transport Logistics or political science
plus six years of professional
experience in the field
or a bachelor degree in the same Fields
plus seven years of experience
or a degree in another field than the
ones mentioned plus nine years of
relevant professional experience now
when saying relevant professional
experience
please read the notice of competition
very carefully because your professional
experience must be acquired in a certain
area and in a certain activity there's a
whole list of areas and activities
explained in the notice of competition
so please check out carefully if your
experience meets those requirements
then of course there is a language
Criterium you need to speak to official
EU languages one at level C1 and the one
at level B2 minimum and one of both
languages must be English for this
competition
how does The Selection procedure look
like it's a standard procedure so it
always starts with an application and of
course there is a testing phase during
which you sit three tests after which
you will be given your results of these
tests and after the
results phase of course we hand over the
lists of successful candidates to the
institutions who will then recruit from
these lists
important to know is that all testing
happens in one single day or remotely so
you do not have to travel to a test
center to sit these tests you do not
need to come to Brussels or Luxembourg
or any other place you can simply take
these tests from your home computer at
home
everybody who
gets invited to these tests and who sits
these tests basically will sit the three
tests mentioned so the reason skills
test the field rated test and the case
study we do not communicate intermediate
results of these tests everybody sees
them all and only at the end you will be
notified of the result
so let's have a look at these different
steps in detail it starts with an
application asset for this application
you need an episode account if you have
one you should use that account if you
don't you can create one easily on our
website
you apply through the home page of our
website as indicated here and you can
apply in any of the 24 languages you
should validate your application by the
7th of November midday Pakistan a latest
so you can go in and out of your
application until then but you must
validated the latest on 7th November
I said everybody who applies gets
invited to the tests
once you are invited you can book a date
and on that date you will sit the three
tests we start with a set of reasoning
skills tests we test your verbal
numerical and abstract reasoning skills
as you can see here the verbal reasoning
is scored on 10 on 20 points sorry and
you need to reach at least 10 out of 20.
so it's a pass fail Market
10 out of 20 is enough whether you have
10 11 12 or more doesn't matter you need
at least 10 out of 20.
for numerical and abstract reasoning
there's a combined pass Mark of 10 out
of 20 again
so again just reaching the pass Mark is
enough
you will sit these reading skills tests
in the other language than English so
not English
I suggest you have a look at our sample
test page on our website because there
you will find indeed sample tests which
familiarize you with these kind of
questions and by having a look at these
and training this you of course will get
better at solving these questions
because first of all there is a level of
difficulty which is good to know and
there is also a Time factor involved you
see the duration mentioned to solve all
these questions so by training this you
of course get better at this
the second test is a field related test
so we test your knowledge in the field
of Transport you find Details In the
notes of competition this test is taken
in English
and you need at least 20 points out of
30. now very probably 20 out of 30 will
not be enough to be among the best
scoring because indeed this time your
scores will be ranked so only the ones
with the highest scores will be able to
find a spot on the list of successful
candidates so 20 out of 30 will probably
not be enough to be amongst the best
ones
the third and last test is a case study
uh you can take it in any of the 24
languages and you need to reach a pass
Mark of 5 out of 10 again just pass fail
so 5 out of 10 is enough through this
case study we do not test the knowledge
in the fields but we test your written
communication skills
okay so it's a test of drafting skills
not knowledge
the best ones ranked are set will be
listed on this Reserve list or list of
successful candidates and those lists
are then handed over to the institutions
we're looking to select 80 successful
candidates and those people can then be
recruited by the different bodies that
have vacancies available
if you still have questions about this
competition please read the notice of
competition very carefully because many
of your questions if not all will be
answered in the notice of competition if
still you have queries please reach out
to us through the web form on our
website
and stay in touch through social media
because we keep you updated on new
opportunities to come in the future
thank you for your attention and bye bye